[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous où vous
regardez l'échiquier mondial duel au
sommaire aujourd'hui deux figures
historiques du communisme le russe
nikita khrouchtchev et le chinois mao
tse ton lors un tag aunis idéologiques
ainsi que leur antipathie personnelle
ont engendré une crise sans précédent au
sein du bloc socialiste
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de nos duellistes c'est le
blitz mao tsé toung né en 1893 à
shaoshan dans la province du yunnan au
sein d'une famille de paysans aisés il
commence à travailler très tôt dans la
ferme de son père mais elle reprend un
peu plus tard des études dans une école
d'instituteur en 1918 il suit l'un de
ses professeurs invités à l'université
de pékin à travers ses lectures mao
découvre alors les idées marxistes et
lors du premier congrès fondateur du
parti communiste chinois à shanghai en
1921 mao il représente sa province d'un
an son cadet nikita khrouchtchev né dans
le village de kelly neuf cas dans la
région de koursk issu d'une famille de
paysans pauvres il commence très tôt à
travailler comme son père dans les mines
du dombass il participe à plusieurs
grèves ouvrières et rencontres à cette
occasion en 1917 lazare kaganovitch
membres du parti bolchévik renommée
parti communiste en 1918 khrouchtchev et
adhère la même année etc aganovic va dès
leur favoriser sa carrière au sein du
parti en ukraine
mao révèle peu à peu ses talents
d'organisateur au sein du parti
communiste chinois au cours de la lutte
contre le komintern le parti
nationaliste qui contrôlent une grande
partie de la chine l'affluence de mao
grandi en 1943 il devient directeur du
comité central du parti après la seconde
guerre mondiale les communistes remporte
définitivement la victoire sur les
nationalistes et en 1949 mao proclame la
république populaire de chine la
carrière de khrouchtchev s'accélère à
partir de 1929 lorsqu'il rejoint à
moscou kaganovitch membre du politburo
khrouchtchev va monter rapidement dans
la hiérarchie du parti à moscou les deux
hommes admirateur de staline passe au
travers des terribles purge de l'époque
après la seconde guerre mondiale à
laquelle khrouchtchev participe en tant
que commissaire politique et redevient
premier secrétaire du parti à moscou
khrouchtchev
rentre alors dans le cercle fermé des
proches collaborateurs de staline quant
à mao ils entament à partir des années
1950 des réformes qui vont s'accélérer
dramatiquement en 1958 avec le grand
bond en avant visant à développer
l'industrie tout en collectivise ans les
terres des famines cause alors des
dizaines de millions de morts et ce
terrible échec affaibli ses positions
mao doit alors partager le pouvoir avec
les réformistes à la mort de staline en
1953 khrouchtchev devient premier
secrétaire du parti et consolide son
pouvoir lors de la lutte pour la
succession dénonçant le culte de la
personnalité de staline et ses
conséquences il se lance à partir de
1958 dans un certain nombre de réformes
en particulier dans le domaine agricole
plutôt bien commencé leurs relations se
sont dégradées au fil des années lors de
sa première visite à pékin en tant que
secrétaire général du parti communiste
khrouchtchev et un cadeau généreux à la
chine et l'acceptent de lui rétrocéder
pour arthur une base navale sur la mer
jaune ayant une importance stratégique
pourtant les différences idéologiques
font vite dégradé les relations entre
les deux hommes le ton amical cèdent la
place aux accusations et injures
mutuelle et aboutit à la rupture entre
pékin et moscou les échanges commerciaux
sont réduits la coopération
technologique et diplomatique est à
l'arrêt à partir de 1960 des
affrontements ont même lieu à la
frontière entre les deux pays faisant
craindre l'éclatement d'un conflit
généralisé qu'est ce qui est à l'origine
de cette rupture entre khrouchtchev et
mao de quoi ce accusé les deux
dirigeants comment leurs confrontations
at-elle affecté l'unité du bloc
communiste et la stabilité régionale
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons edouard husson historien
professeur des universités directeur de
la rédaction du courrier des stratèges
messieurs son bonjour bonjour pourriez
vous nous décrire la personnalité de mao
zedong cette icône du communisme chinois
écoutez oui on peut effectivement
s'intéresser à la personnalité de de mao
qui est absolument
fondamental pour le communisme chinois
aujourd'hui encore un puisque il y a il
y avait eu en union soviétique
on en reparlera une déstalinisation il
n'y a jamais eu de démobilisation en
chine jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc
effectivement l'homme il s'agit pas de
retracer sa sa biographie ce que je
voudrais c'est simplement mettre en
mettre en valeur trois points le premier
c'est le fait que mao toute sa vie est
resté finalement extrêmement chinois il
a il avait très peu de connaissance du
monde extérieur
et ça je crois que c'est extrêmement
important c'est dû à l'immensité à la
démographie mais c'est quelque chose à
comprendre qui est sans doute sa
caractéristique par rapport à tous les
autres leaders du 20e siècle la deuxième
caractéristique
c'est que il a
effectivement connu des années encore
beaucoup plus difficile que l'école est
responsable communiste russe avant la
révolution de 1917 puisque il a dû comme
on le sait est effectuée la longue
marche et échapper à une perte à une
persécution énorme du parti communiste
et donc ça a forgé un caractère
particulièrement trempé qui était qu'ils
étaient capables de d'affronter le
colosse soviétique au sein du bloc
communiste la troisième caractéristique
et je finirai par ça c'est que une fois
qu'il est qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir
suprême ce qui
l'a emporté chez lui c'est l'idée selon
laquelle il il était l'héritier des
empereurs chinois et il il reconstitue
est la puissance chinoise
alors cette année aussi avec une dérive
personnelle de plus en plus affirmée et
en particulier une une vie personnelle
qui imitait de plus en plus celle des
des plus grands tyrans de
de l'histoire chinoise avec en
particulier la dissolution des moeurs et
est donc mao est une personnalité de ce
fait très complexe et donc face à lui un
nikita khrouchtchev qui est beaucoup
moins charismatique selon vous je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse dire ça il faut
se rappeler qu'à l'époque à l'époque de
de khrouchtchev il l'était il était
considéré comme un comme un leader
énergique alors moins charismatique au
sens où il exerçait - d'attraction sur
les foules soviétique que mao sur les
foules chinoise ça on est bien d'accord
et c'est l'une des caractéristiques de
mao à la différence de staline le spen
denis lamard ressemble plus à lénine
puisque il a un vrai un vrai pouvoir
d'attraction sur les foules sur les
publics quand il les harangues mais il
faut se rappeler que khrouchtchev était
extrêmement caractéristiques de la
génération des bolchéviques y avait qui
avait percé sous staline et il avait
amplement participé au politique
stalinienne aux purges khrouchtchev et
est un l'un des bourreaux de l'ukraine
sa région d'origine dans les années 1930
et donc il avait il avait énormément
d'énergie en fait khrouchtchev a plutôt
plutôt chuté parce qu'il a présumé de
ses de ses forces face aux états unis et
que
l'appareil soviétique ne lui a pas
pardonné l'échec dans la crise des
missiles de cuba merci beaucoup monsieur
huchon nous allons poursuivre notre
alice tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore
l'antipathie personnel entre nikita
khrouchtchev et mao tsé toung devenu
ennemi a failli coûter très cher au
monde entier deux visions différentes
sur presque tout y compris l'idéologie
socialiste ont mis une croix sur le
rapprochement entre l'urss et la chine
débutée après la seconde guerre mondiale
entre l'urss et le parti communiste
chinois le rapprochement s'intensifient
après la seconde guerre mondiale moscou
accorde un soutien économique et
militaire aux communistes dans leur
lutte contre le parti nationaliste
soutenu par les états unis c'est
notamment grâce à cette aide que la
guerre se conclut par une victoire des
communistes chinois qui proclame le 1er
octobre 1949 la république populaire de
chine l'urss est le premier pays à
reconnaître le nouvel état en décembre
1949 mao tsé toung effectue sa première
visite à moscou d'une durée sans
précédent
deux mois
cette rencontre personnelle donne un
élan au développement des liens
bilatéraux
en 1950 les deux états signent un traité
d'amitié d'alliance et d'assistance
mutuelle ils s'engagent à ne pas
participer à des alliances militaires
l'un contre l'autre et à fournir une
assistance en cas d' attaque pendant les
années qui suivent la coopération se
renforce dans le domaine économique
l'urss est le principal partenaire
économique de pékin moscou envoie en
chine des spécialistes pour développer
l'industrie chinoise depuis les
constructions automobiles et
aéronautiques jusqu'à l'ingénierie
électrique dans le contexte de la guerre
froide pékin et moscou coopère de plus
en plus en matière de défense au début
des années 50 ils sont engagés dans la
guerre en cours et où ils soutiennent le
nord pro communiste pourtant le ton des
relations change avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir de khrouchtchev en urss leur
confrontation commence lors de la
première visite de khrouchtchev à pékin
1954 après les négociations qui se sont
plutôt bien déroulées le dirigeant
soviétique rentrer à moscou sans
emporter le cas d'oddo mao tsé toung
plusieurs volumes d'oeuvre de staline
traduit en chinois ce geste diplomatique
est passée quasi inaperçue à l'époque
pourtant c'est la personnalité de
staline qui fera monter la tension entre
les deux leaders dès 1956 l'année où se
tient le 20ème congrès du parti
communiste à moscou lors d'une réunion à
huit clos khrouchtchev se livre à une
démolition de staline leader intouchable
de tous les communistes jusqu alors dans
son discours il reproche à staline de
promouvoir le culte de la personnalité
et l'accusent de perversion grave des
principes du parti de répression de
masse et d'erreurs stratégiques pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale
staline s'est retiré de ces instructions
programmatique direct et clair de lénine
staline a orienté le parti orienter les
organes du nkvd vers la terreur de masse
cette terreur s'est avéré être en
réalité dirigé non contre les restes des
classes exploiteuses vaincu mais contre
les cadres honnêtes du parti et de
l'état soviétique
mao apprend la nouvelle avec
stupéfaction dans un de ses entretiens
avec l'ambassadeur soviétique à pékin il
dénonce une grave erreur du côté du
pouvoir soviétique
vous avez complètement renoncé à une
épée tels que staline vous avez jeté cet
ep en conséquence les ennemis l'on
ramassé pour pouvoir nous tuer vos
action équivalent a ramassé une pierre
puis à la jetée sur vos pieds aspirant
au leadership dans le camp socialiste
mao fait émerger son propre courant dans
le communisme le maoïsme et correspond à
une application stricte du marxisme
léninisme aux conditions particulières
de la chine et dénonce l'impossibilité
de la victoire du socialisme à l'échelle
mondiale sans la destruction totale de
l'impérialisme la moitié de l'humanité
détruites l'autre moitié restera mais
l'impérialisme sera complètement détruit
il n'y aura que le socialisme dans le
monde entier dans quelques années il y
aura à nouveau 2 milliards 700 millions
d'habitants est certainement plus
khrouchtchev lui cherche au contraire à
renouveler certaines dispositions du
marxisme léninisme le dirigeant
soviétique est contre révolution
mondiale et prône le passage pacifique
du capitalisme vers le socialisme tout
en admettant leur coexistence pacifique
les idées qui valent à khrouchtchev
d'être accusé de révisionnisme par pékin
alors que mao s'est vu coller
l'étiquette de dogmatisme par le pouvoir
soviétique
ces différences idéologiques complexifie
davantage les relations entre mao et
khrouchtchev chacun se considérant le
véritable leader du camp socialiste
d'ailleurs khrouchtchev ne voyait pas en
mao de rival de taille il marche sans
pantalon mais parle du communisme selon
une phrase bien connue qui n'a fait
qu'amplifier l'antipathie personnel
entre les deux dirigeants selon un
diplomate soviétique de l'époque m'a au
traité khrouchtchev d'idiot devant son
entourage khrouchtchev lui qualifié le
leader du parti communiste chinois deux
vieux patouillard mao plus âgée que son
homologue refusé de reconnaître la
supériorité de khrouchtchev dans le camp
socialiste
cette antipathie personnelle se
manifestait aussi dans les gestes
diplomatiques en 1959 la république
populaire de chine fête ses 10 ans
khrouchtchev est en tête de la
délégation soviétique qui se rend à
pékin mais cette visite diplomatique se
passe mal lors de la rencontre mao se
permet de fumer devant le visage de
khrouchtchev alors que ce dernier des
tests la fumée le dirigeant chinois
invite ensuite son hôte à nager dans une
piscine sachant pertinemment que
khrouchtchev est en âge heure médiocre
après sept séances de natation le chef
d'état soviétique arrête sa visite et
retourne à moscou plus tôt que prévu
les relations sino soviétique vont se
dégrader dans les années à venir mettant
les deux pays au bord d'une
confrontation directe ce n'est qu'avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir de gorbatchev en
urss que le dialogue reprend alors
comment cette rupture sino soviétique at
elle affecté l'unité du bloc socialiste
de l'époque quel levier khrouchtchev
utilise est il pour mettre la pression
sur mao enfin comment le leader des
communistes chinois cherchait-il à
réduire l'influencé de moscou sur pékin
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
dès l'arrivée au pouvoir de khrouchtchev
l'antagonisme entre les deux leaders
entraîne vite une dégradation des liens
économiques et de la coopération en
matière de défense et de technologie
dans tous ces domaines l'urss avait à
l'époque un avantage de taille sur la
chine proche partenaire au début l'urss
et la chine ont un poids différent dans
de nombreux domaines en termes de
superficie le territoire de l'union
soviétique est plus de deux fois plus
grand que celui de la république
populaire de chine par ailleurs la chine
est beaucoup plus peuplée que l'urss on
y comptait 667 millions d'habitants en
1960 contre seulement 212,4 millions en
urss dans le domaine technologique
l'urss et des avantages significatifs
la mise au point d'une bombe à hydrogène
lancement du premier satellite et du
premier vaisseau spatial avec un homme à
bord la construction des premières
centrales nucléaires en outre l'urss est
l'un des plus grands producteurs
mondiaux de pétrole de gaz d'acier et de
fonte et même de produits chimiques
la chine est majoritairement un pays
agricole la tentative de mao tsé toung
de l'industrialiser à la fin des années
50 s'achève par un succès à demi teinte
la course aux armements débouche sur le
développement du complexe militaire en
urss moscou met en service le premier
sous marin nucléaire dans les années 50
vers 1960 l'armée soviétique compte plus
de 3 5 millions de soldats le nombre le
plus élevé dans le monde quant à la
chine elle dénombre 2 5 millions de
soldats et dépend de l'urss pour le
soutien logistique
1954 première visite de khrouchtchev à
pékin le dirigeant soviétique veut
conforter une alliance fragile son
premier pas inviter des ouvriers chinois
à travailler en sibérie pour alléger le
chômage en chine khrouchtchev croit
cette offre avantageuse pour les deux
pays mauvais calcul mao zedong y voient
une insulte
donc elle aussi l'urss perçoit la chine
comme une source de main d'oeuvre brut
les pays impérialistes occidentaux nous
percevait de la même manière cet épisode
sera suivi par des dissensions plus
durable comme la question de l'armé
nucléaire vers 1954 les états unis et la
russie en possède déjà le secret mao est
déterminé à les rejoindre mais la
technologie échappe à la chine agraire
et le grand frère staline refuse de
partager la recette or khrouchtchev et
plus jeunes moins expérimentés et plus
conciliant pour mao zedong ce sont des
signes de faiblesse dont il faut
profiter du coup il relance la demande
dès 1954 pas de chance khrouchtchev
oppose un refus catégorique
n'est ce pas assez que nous nous
possédions la bombe atomique nous allons
vous protéger au cas où nous frapperons
l'ennemi à votre place nikita
khrouchtchev prône la non prolifération
et veut éviter une guerre nucléaire à
tout prix le chinois ne partage pas
cette prudence pour éviter un
affrontement idéologique et obtenir
l'armé nucléaire mao changent de
tactique en 1955 il commence par signer
un accord de coopération sur l'atome
pacifique avec moscou le rss fourni à
pékin des technologies construit son
premier réacteur forme ces spécialistes
coopération atteint son pic en 1957
khrouchtchev accepte finalement de
partager la technologie des armes
nucléaires satisfait mao veut aller
encore plus loin en 1958 il demande à
l'urss la technologie des sous-marins
moscou avance ces conditions même à eau
rejette ces demandes qu'ils considèrent
comme humiliant puis il annonce mettre
le cap sur l'indépendance stratégique et
renonce à l'union militaire avec l'urss
à ce moment-là khrouchtchev décide de
rompre la coopération nucléaire une
confrontation qui enclenche
l'écroulement définitive des vestiges de
l'alliance rappelons que la chine doit
son industrialisation en grande partie à
le rss surtout dans les années 50 depuis
la planification économique jusqu'à la
construction d' usine et de machines
l'union soviétique s'est montré plus que
généreuse et l'acharnement de mao contre
son bienfaiteur déçoit profondément
nikita khrouchtchev en 1960 et le retire
tous les spécialistes soviétique de la
chine 1400 hommes puis coupe la ligne de
crédit de pékin est ronde et dizaine
d'accords économiques vers 1963 le
volume des échanges commerciaux
bilatéraux et divisé par trois et les
livraisons des machines-outils
soviétique par 40 les tensions vont même
au-delà du domaine économique et
débouche sur des tensions militaires dès
l'été 1960 la frontière sino soviétique
devient la scène dans nombre croissant
d'incidents militaire plus de 5000
accrochage
lieu durant la seule année 1962 en cause
de vieilles prétentions territoriales
chinoises que mao décidera ni mais ils
estiment injuste certes un traité
sino-russe sur les frontières conclu
avant l'arrivée des communistes au
pouvoir et accuse le rss de posséder 1,5
million de kilomètres carrés de
territoire qui ne lui appartiendrait pas
nikita khrouchtchev projette ses
prétentions et s'enfonce dans l'escaladé
elle continuera après sa démission son
apogée aura lieu en 1969 lors du conflit
frontalier sino soviétique la mort de
mao zedong sept ans après ne change pas
grand chose au milieu des années 1960
les critiques de khrouchtchev
s'intensifie au sein du parti communiste
une partie des membres de ce dernier lui
reproche des échecs dans la mise en
place d'un certain nombre de réformes
internes notamment celles du secteur
agricole son culte de la personnalité et
aussi ses erreurs à l'international le
12 octobre 1964 le parti convoque une
réunion sous la direction de leonid
brejnev où toutes ces accusations sont
formulées khrouchtchev et contraint de
démissionner une fois la retraite il
enregistre ses mémoires sur dictaphone
khrouchtchev mort le 11 septembre 10 971
d'une crise cardiaque le nom du
dirigeant soviétique en disgrâce est
rarement mentionnée dans les médias
jusqu'à la pérestroïka
après la démission de khrouchtchev mao
dirigera le pays pendant encore douze
ans en 1966 il lance la révolution
culturelle mobilisant la jeunesse contre
les intellectuels et les cadres du parti
suspect de droitisme ce mouvement
entraîne des millions de victimes mais
mao renforce ses positions cependant à
partir de 1971 la santé de mao décline
éclate alors une lutte pour le pouvoir
et radicaux de gauche dont fait partie
les pousses de mao contre un groupe
pragmatique avec dunks 0 ping mao meurt
le 9 septembre 1976 ses funérailles
réunissent plus d'un million de chinois
le corps du défunt et embaumé et exposé
pendant un an après sa mort dans un
mausolée la lutte pour le pouvoir est
finalement remportée par deng xiaoping
qui prend les rênes du pays
d'abord l'opposition des deux chefs
communistes se joue principalement sur
le plan bilatéral pourtant à mesure que
leurs conflits progresse il détend a
aussi largement sur les relations avec
les autres pays en 1956 khrouchtchev
critique staline mao forgeant un courant
rival pro stalinien et se sert de cette
nouvelle arme pour s'imposer dans le
camp socialiste
en pologne par exemple une insurrection
menaces du pouvoir communiste
l'urss vole à son secours une action
dénoncée par la chine qui accuse moscou
de paternalisme dans d'autres pays
socialistes l'histoire se répète le
monde social et se range derrière
khrouchtchev mais mao zedong n'a pas dit
son dernier mot en europe il arrache à
moscou son seul allié méditerranéen
l'albanie le pays n'accepte pas à l'
acharnement anti stalinien de
khrouchtchev c est une menace pour le
pouvoir denver hodja un stalinien
fidèles du coup dès 1956 talbani tourner
le dos à son ex allié soviétique en 1960
la corée du nord se range aussi du côté
de pékin et soutient sa version du
socialisme mondial la nouvelle ligne de
fracture idéologique apparaît mais les
tensions entre mao et khrouchtchev ne
s'arrête pas là en 1954 les deux
duellistes voit les etats-unis comme le
principal adversaire cependant dès 1956
khrouchtchev adouci le ton et obtient
une percée en 1959 washington l'invite
première fois de l'histoire aux yeux de
pékin c'est une trahison de plus en 1962
une guerre nucléaire et évité de
justesse grâce au retrait des missiles
soviétiques de cuba mao dénonce pourtant
une capitulation de moscou khrouchtchev
l'accusent d'instiguer à un conflit
nucléaire les chinois disent que j'ai eu
peur bien sûr que j'ai eu peur il faut
être fou pour ne pas avoir peur de la
guerre mao est frustré par la façon de
khrouchtchev de mener la diplomatie
communiste il ne peut aucunement compte
et donc sur son soutien la chine et
l'inde entre 1959 dans un conflit à la
frontière pour moscou les deux pays sont
d'importants partenaires économiques
khrouchtchev ne s'immisce pas et reste
neutre la chine se pressent à leur
d'accuser moscou d' manqué à la
solidarité socialiste plusieurs
initiatives pacifiques de khrouchtchev
sont rejetées par mao tse ton parmi
elles le démantèlement au simultanée de
le temps et de l'organisation du traité
de varsovie ou encore la fermeture de
toutes les bases dans les pays tiers
alors comment la rivalité khrouchtchev
mao at-elle remodeler le paysage
géopolitique pour y voir plus clair nous
rejoignons edouard husson historien
professeur des universités directeur de
la rédaction du courrier des stratèges
monsieur sont comment la scission entre
l'urss et la chine at elle affecté le
camp socialiste
c'est la scission entre le entre l'urss
et la chine a été quelque chose
d'absolument
dramatique pour le mouvement communiste
international
puisque cela obligé à prendre position
entre la fidélité au stalinisme ou à
l'union soviétique on va dire en tout
cas et le fait de passer du côté de ce
qui était vu comme tout d'un coup comme
les comme les adversaires alors 7 cet
affrontement s'est transposée aussi sur
le plan doctrinal
puisque mao avait proposé une autre
façon d'envisager
la révolution puisque le mouvement
communiste chinois était arrivé au
pouvoir en s'appuyant sur les sur les
paysans alors que staline avait des
coups là qu'ils aient commencé et dans
d'autre part l'appel était très fort sur
un certain nombre de pays du 10 du
tiers-monde qui effectivement on pouvait
penser que le modèle chinois leur l'oral
est plus que le modèle soviétique le
dernier point le dernier point sur
lequel il faut insister c'est que dans
le monde occidental cela fait émerger un
courant dit maoïste est dans un monde
occidental où le prestige de l'union
soviétique avait chuté après la la
répression à 1 à budapest en 1956 les
jeunes générations se sont volontiers
tourné vers mao et vers la chine en n'y
connaissant rien d'ailleurs en ignorant
toutes les toutes les horreurs du
communisme chinois mais en se disant que
c'était l'avenir du communisme et plus
globalement comment la rupture entre
l'urss et la chine at elle modifié le
rapport des forces sur l'échiquier
mondial
du point de vue géopolitique
il y a eu une période de latence il ne
faut pas oublier que la rupture sino
soviétique elle se elle se déroule sur
une entre 10 et 15 ans entre la deuxième
moitié des années 50 et la fin des
années 60 avec les et tensions très
fortes à la frontière et les
affrontements à la frontière entre entre
les deux pays en 1969 et il a fallu du
temps aussi
parce que les états unis n'ont pas
imaginé tout de suite qu'il pouvait
jouer une carte chinoise pour
contrebalancer l'union soviétique ça
n'est que avec l'élection de richard
nixon à la fin des années 60 que les que
les américains ont commencé à changer de
conception avec l'idée d'un équilibre
des puissances en fait il y avait eu une
tradition cynophile dans l'histoire
américaine puis une déception
du fait de la révolution 1949 et donc le
parti républicain américain à renouer
avec cette tradition là et le
bouleversement c'est fait donc en deux
temps d'abord les gens ont pris acte de
ce changement et puis ensuite les
etats-unis ont décidé d'en tirer des
conséquences dans leur alliance merci
beaucoup edouard husson je rappelle vous
êtes historien professeur des
universités directeur de la rédaction du
courrier des stratèges merci pour cet
éclairage
aujourd'hui cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]